you can use custom dashboards to tailor
the monitoring experience to your
environment to create your first custom
dashboard click dashboards at the top of
the screen and create here we'll add
three charts to our new dashboard first
I'll choose a resource type of Google
App Engine module and then I'll I'll
search for latency metrics here I'll add
the response latency x' 95th percentile
so now I have a chart that displays the
95th percentile latency for each of my
App Engine modules I'll let a second
chart for the App Engine responses for
each of the modules so again I'll type
responses to filter the list and then
I'll choose total responses and click
Save and I'll add a third chart for
Google compute engine instances in this
case I'm primarily interested in CPU
usage for each of my instances and I'll
click Save so now I have three charts on
my custom dashboard I can also change
the layout of that dashboard perhaps I
want to view it in a three column view I
can also rearrange the charts on the
dashboard by clicking on any of the
titles and moving it in into its
location if I want to look at the
dashboard in full-screen mode I can
click the fullscreen icon in the top
right hand corner of the screen this is
particularly useful for viewing the
dashboard on a large LED screen in an
office to the left of the fullscreen
icon you can access the settings for the
chart such as the setting to show all of
the legends on the charts and to the
left of that I can choose to enable auto
refresh for my charts and then if I
zoomed in any of the charts to a
particular time frame I can always use
the reset zoom icon to reset the time
frame
all of my charts and then finally if I
wanted to choose a specific time frame
for the charts I can click on any of the
links in the top right hand corner to
view that time frame here I'm looking at
a day's worth of data across all of my
charts and so those are the core
capabilities of the custom dashboard
feature there are many more capabilities
for you to take advantage of as you
familiarize yourself with custom
dashboards